[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
ici au parlement européen à strasbourg
pour 30 minutes d'actualité
c'est parti dans cette émission
direction les pays bas dans un mois les
citoyens sont appelés aux urnes
et comme en france le pvv le parti de la
liberté de geert builder risque de
réaliser un score historique au coeur de
son programme le rejet des minorités de
l'islam et des musulmans
un programme qui suscite tensions et
polémiques mais d'abord l'actualité
à quelques semaines des 60 ans du traité
de rome traité fondateur de ce qui
allait devenir l'union européenne
l'horizon s'obscurcit pour l'union en
cause les politiques risquent elles
traversent le break site d'élection de
donald trump
alors quel avenir pour l'europe c'est la
question de la semaine et elle est posée
par aurélie la face
[Musique]
à quelques semaines du sommet de rome
qui célèbrera les 60 ans du traité
fondateur de l'union européenne les
contours de l'europe de demain semble
toujours plus incertain dimanche dernier
jean claude juncker a déclaré jeter
l'épongé président de la commission
européenne de la dernière chance selon
ses propres termes lors de son
investiture en 2014
il ne briguera pas de second mandat dans
deux ans une annonce qui s'accompagne
d'un constat pour lui l'union
européennes évoluent dans des directions
différentes selon les pays
des directions difficilement compatibles
entre elles crise de la dette crise des
réfugiés briques site montée des
populismes les défis sont légion et
n'ont jamais semblé si indépassable face
à ce constat les européens s'organisent
au parlement 3 rapport sur l'avenir de
l'union sont mises au vote
au sommet de la valette début février
les dirigeants européens ont posé les
jalons de l'europe de demain
angela merkel a exprimé la position des
pays fondateurs l'histoire récente de
l'union a montré qu'il y aura une union
européenne à différentes vitesses que
tous ne vont pas participer à chaque
fois à toutes les étapes d'intégration
l'avenir de l'europe
ce serait donc une union à deux vitesses
une possible solution pour éviter
l'implosion
quel avenir pour l'union européenne est
ce une union à plusieurs vitesses comme
le signifiait en gala merkel pour en
débattre je reçois pervenche berès
bonjour vous êtes députée européenne
française membre du groupe socialiste et
vous avez signé l'un de ces rapports
dont qui a été mise au vote cette
semaine au parlement européen
en face de vous philippe lambert dit
bonjour vous êtes député belge membre du
groupe des verts vous êtes président
même ou de ce groupe
enfin à côté de frank engel vous
êtes-vous luxembourgeois et vous êtes
membre du groupe ppe première question
peut-être fringale jean claude juncker
qui jette l'épongé deux ans avant la fin
de son mandat elle c'est à dire que
l'europe de ses pôles y crise qui
l'avait nommé à l'époque où il a pris
son mandat en 2014 la ashley a
premièrement ce n'est pas vraiment
nouveau dans la mesure où je croyais
détecté dans ces informations à la
maison il est vrai que peu de noms
luxembourgeoise soucie beaucoup de la
presse luxembourgeoise mais il avait
déjà la seule à se comprendre il ya
longtemps déjà qu'il ne ferait pas
seulement de la lassitude qui ne
souhaiteraient pas un deuxième où que ce
soit de lassitude ou pas vous voyez le
problème est toujours le même et
enquêtant que l'équilibré social
institutionnel de l'union ne sera pas
bouleversée nous n'en sortirons pas vous
pouvez avoir le président de la
commission le plus déterminé du monde si
on face de lui il ya un conseil européen
soit dit entre parenthèses je
souhaiterais l'abolir labo liste c'est
l'institution la plus contre productive
qui a jamais existé sur le sol européen
ferment fermons la parenthèse si vous
avez le meilleur président de la
commission avec en face un conseil
européen dans la substance politique
réactionnaire au plus haut point
ça n'avance dans aucune direction veut
malheureusement c'est le conseil qui
l'uci n'est pas le président de la
commission aux carences berès abolir le
conseil européen car il est
contre-productif
est ce que c'est une bonne idée vous
n'iriez pas jusque là président je ne
place pas au candidat socialiste de
proposer de renoncer à nettement après
la question de l'équilibré entre la
commission et le conseil européens si on
veut vraiment qu'il ya une dynamique
on sait bien je conteste d'ailleurs le
coeur de plusieurs des rapports qui ont
été remis à sur l'avenir de l'europe
encore comment est ce que ça marche en
europe ça marche quand à la dir de
chaque état et des responsables
politiques qui sont capables de dépenses
dépasser leur intérêt national et donc
de faire conjuguer l'intérêt de leur
pays avec une vision plus généreuse qui
les dépasse qui est une vision
européenne et qu' il y a à bruxelles où
même à strasbourg un bon interlocuteur
qui arrive à mailler tout ça avec ma
propre vision sa propre dynamique
culture du consensus finalement qu'il
irait au delà on sort des
particularismes nationaux
c'est pas qu'une question du consensus
est ce qu'un consensus est parfois ça
peut mener nulle part il faut quand même
qu'il ya une dynamique faut qu'ils aient
une vision aucune envie de défendre
l'europe comme l'a fait dans cet
hémicycle
il n'y a pas si longtemps on en compte
cette session le président autrichien
dit que qu'il renonce à se représenter
on peut voir cette bouteille à moitié
vide ou à moitié plein
ils se seraient représentés on en
retient il s'accroche au pouvoir il en a
rien à fiche de ce qu'il va faire pour
moi les deux ans 18 qui sont écoulés il
renoncé et ont dit il abandonne le
le bateau vous voyez comme c'est facile
la politique non jean claude juncker a
dit quelque chose qui je crois n'était
pas tout à fait un scoop parce que
jamais dit qu'il était là pour dix ans
en même temps ça veut dire que il se
donne d'une certaine manière carte
blanche pour faire quelque chose de ces
deux ans il y qui lui reste alors qu'il
a dit que c'était la commission de la
dernière chance donc à lui manière une
manière en fait de mettre aussi
peut-être les états au pied du mur à la
veille de 60 ans étaient graves
il faut qu'il se donne les moyens de
faire de ces deux ans quelque chose
philippe lambert qu'est ce que vous en
pensez mais moi j'ai vu après le
référendum britannique un jean claude
juncker venir en plénière sans direction
on voyait qu'il avait perdu la boussole
il nous ça a tenu un discours de 40
minutes assez décousu on comprend bien
en tout cas moi c'est mon interprétation
jean claude juncker ne comprends pas ce
qui est en train de se passer
je dis aujourd'hui les dépècent débitent
des réseaux et des personnes je pense
qu'il ne perçoit pas ce qui est en train
de se passer je vis en belgique dans un
pays qui est fédéraliste européen depuis
toujours et je sens monter y compris
dans mon électorat dont des gens on va
dire de centre gauche
je sens monter une vague de rejet de
l'union européenne auprès de gens qui
naturellement enfin je veux dire en
belgique le fait qu'on ait pas de
souveraineté à nous tout seul c'est une
évidence je dire en france on croit
encore qu'on est une grande nation et
que on est capable d'exister seul mais
nous n'avons même plus cette illusion
jeudi en belgique petit pays de 10
millions d'habitants on sait bien que ça
n'est que au travers de l'union
européenne que nous pouvons peser bien
même en belgique on commence à se dire
oui mais si c'est pour une europe est
une union européenne du pouvoir des
multinationales qui refuse d'interdire
les perturbateurs endocriniens qui fait
des traités dit vrai changement
favorable aux multinationales bref qui
pousse l'agenda néolibéral
franchement on n'en veut pas ce mort
qu'est ce qu'on constate c'est que le
référendum britannique en tout cas la
lecture que j'en ai c'est que les
laissés pour compte de ces politiques
néolibérales à un moment où envie
d'envoyer un bras d'honneur aux élites à
ceux qui nous dirigent et ceux qui nous
dirigent répondants dix ans continuons
dans la même voie alors justement non
dans la même voie play dessus du
somnambulisme le dire gentiment ses de
l'autisme autrement dit je n'entends pas
je suis
immunisés contre l'environnement dans
lequel je suis je continue à tracer ma
route donc on y aller par exemple les
remontées l'idée donc de cette union à
deux vitesses ou à différentes vitesses
selon l'américain s'est complètement
déconnectés selon vous mais non celle
mais c'est pas la question de la
question c'est pour faire quoi
oui je veux dire l'union à plusieurs
vitesses et exige suis dit ce n'est pas
un nouveau projet de l'euro stoxx 28
donc schengen ne l'appliquent pas tous
les tous les états de l'union donc on
est déjà dedans dans une europe à
plusieurs configurations il ya plusieurs
vitesses donc ça ça n'a rien de neuf à
la question c'est pour faire quoi alors
justement par google pour faire quoi
c'est une europe à deux vitesses pour
faire plus que ce qu'on fait
actuellement dans le domaine où ça
contre eux pour proférer que ce n'est
pas très vendeur en fait pour une
population pour une môme est nommée
opinion publique qui a de plus en plus
tendance à rejeter l'europe quoi
l'opinion publique fait ce qu'on lui
insinue à la fin du compte et l'opinion
publique s'est fait dire pendant des
décennies par trop de médias par trop
trop de partis politique par trop de soi
disant dirigeants par trop le détenteur
de la vérité morale de la soi-disant
société civile que l'europe est mauvaise
néo libérale à la solde de la grosse
financer je ne sais pas quoi encore
alors que moi je ne suis pas à l'assaut
de la grande finance
oui c'est un fédéraliste européen
convaincu qui essayent de bataille et
1000 fédéraliste aujourd'hui ça ça parle
plus à personne 30 mondial est ce qu il
ya quelque chose de concret qu'on ne
vende on en a marre blême ce n'est pas
que ça me parle plus à personne le
problème c'est que personne n'en parle
plus sincères d'un pas vrai mais je suis
désolé j'en parle de tous les jours j'ai
dit je suis un homme bien convaincu
autant que vous monsieur engel oui et
mais ce que je sens non douce et que le
public c'est le public auquel je
m'adresse devient de plus en plus
sceptique par rapport à l'idée même
d'intégration politique européenne et
moi je dis toujours en belgique je peux
être opposés à la politique du
gouvernement belge et je le suis
radicalement des bras pour autant plaidé
la dissolution de la belgique je suis
aujourd'hui en opposants aux politiques
nées au but néo libérales menées par les
majorités politiques au niveau de
l'union européenne
c'est pas pour ça que je vais plaider la
dissolution de l'union européenne je
veux par contre des majorités qui à
notre maire d'ambarès
moi ce que ce que je crois surtout c'est
que
toute la difficulté pour parler d'europe
et pourrait intéresser les gens à la
question européenne
c'est qu'à la fois on parle du très haut
et du très bas ou du très grand et du
très petit quand on parle du très grand
c'est que peuvent les pays de l'union
européenne face à la russie de monsieur
poutine
face aux états unis de monsieur trump
face à la chine face à sable même en
syrie s'ils ne sont pas unis et ça
évidemment ça ne parle pas forcément au
quotidien des gens mais dans une
approche géostratégique comprendre ce
qu'est le poids des uns et des autres ça
a de l'importance
or cet équilibre là il est bousculé par
le fait que les britanniques veulent
partir c'est le bric site il ya quelque
chose d'assez par grappillant c'est que
c'est quand même le pays qui nous avait
vendu le plus le libre échange les
vertus du libéralisme de la
financiarisation de l'économie
et c'est ce en fait qu'ils se sont pris
le couteau dans la figure du foot est
d'en tirer les leçons
il faut peut-être que l'europe
s'interroge aujourd'hui sur lui comprend
l'évasion fiscale la définition minimums
sociaux
ça fait effectivement partie des grands
dossiers auxquels on est confrontés
question c'est est-ce qu'à la volonté
politique d'y aller si demain l'union
européenne dit ou en tout cas un
sous-ensemble de l'union européenne un
groupe de pays volontaires disent ok
nous allons harmoniser l'impôt des
sociétés entre nous pour éviter que les
multinationales se joue des différences
entre nos régimes fiscaux
si une série de chefs des gouvernements
et leurs milices des finances y c'est ça
qu'on peut faire je pense que l'europe
retrouvera du crédit auprès des citoyens
si l'europe dit eh bien nous allons
organiser une convergence vers le haut
en matière de couverture sociale de
protection pour nos concitoyens en fait
c'est ce qu'on avait fait lorsque la
grèce l'italie l'espagne et le portugal
avaient rejoint on avait observé une
convergence accélérer cela prouve que
l'idée en fait vers le sentiment
européen de sept autres nations
si l'europe est vue comme un ascenseur
social je pense qu'on retrouvera le
l'accord de nos concitoyens
c'est ce que j'ose le rapport que j'ai
effectivement et les autres rapports
alors je voudrais qu'on avance parce
qu'il ya
une autre thématique vous comme vous le
savez ils sont nombreux au sein de ce
parlement
beaucoup de partis politiques dits
populistes nationalistes
aujourd'hui commence a souhaité enfin
souhaite d'autres briques site
possiblement en france possiblement aux
pays bas nous avons été justement aux
pays-bas dans quelques semaines les
citoyens sont appelés aux urnes garde
ville de rallier de marine le pen leader
du pvv le parti de la liberté risque de
réaliser un score important son
programme la fin de l'union européenne
mais également le rejet des minorités
des musulmans et l'interdiction de
l'islam
reportage par jérôme rabier
[Musique]
c'est une lame de fond qui progresser
cette année
gertwiller c'est son parti de la liberté
le pvv se met à rêver
résolument anti européen et anti islam
il pourrait devenir la principale force
politique des pays bas c'est au coeur du
pouvoir à l'est que de niveaux czink
sympathisants rêve tout d'une victoire
en mars 2010 est donc voici le parlement
ici travail guebwiller j'espère qu'il
sera nommé premier ministre que moins
d'immigrants viendront pays bas et moins
d'islam aussi est aussi un meilleur
système de santé leur modèle c'est le
décret controversé de donald trump
interdisant l'entrée du territoire à des
ressortissants de sept pays musulmans
mais encore plus strictes
le leader populiste néerlandais veut
fermer les mosquées et faire interdire
le corps je pense que s'ils gardent
wylder s'est nommé premier ministre il
mettra fin à l'immigration surtout pour
les ressortissants des pays musulmans
une parole de plus en plus libéré sur
l'immigration et l'islam qui se répand
sans que son leader n'est vraiment
besoin de faire campagne mais via les
réseaux sociaux noni administre lui même
certaines de ses pages dans la rue il ya
beaucoup de donc les réseaux sociaux
c'est vraiment lui pour pouvoir exprimer
son opinion
cette page est la plus nationalistes les
pays-bas patrie pour montrer qu'on est
fiers de notre pays qu'on veut garder
notre culture regardez celle là nous
avons déjà 22 mille abonnés l'extrême
droite néerlandaise a toutes les chances
d'arriver en tête mais peu d'espoir de
gouverner dans un système proportionnel
ou les grandes coalitions sont la règle
pour diriger le pays
les autres partis refus de s'allier à
lui et maintienne le dialogue avec la
communauté musulmane
dans ce climat de tensions identitaires
bonjour et bienvenue entrée ce soir
c'est une délégation d'un parti
centriste libéral qui est l'invité du
conseil des mosquées marocaines dans la
banlieue du trec'h pour deux heures des
échanges sur la place de l'islam dans la
société c'est suggérer que la solution
c'est que les marocains disparaissent
des pays bas et s'il n'importe quoi ces
gens sont néerlandais ils sont nés ici
ce que propose une d'earth c'est un peu
comme le saint nicolas qui apporte les
cadeaux aux enfants
croyez vous encore aux contes de fées
moi je suis trop vieille pour ça
[Musique]
ils vont church a fait danser
vous devez comprendre que gears they
will doors et son pv on en guise de
programme une seule page format a4
c'est très court mais très lourd il a
déclaré à plusieurs reprises qu'il veut
fermer toutes les mosquées il a dit
qu'il veut aller confisqué tous les
corps en dans nos maisons
les attaques islamophobes contre les
lieux de culte se multiplient une
tension qui se retrouvent dans la vie
politique du pays
comme gears builders silvana simone
c'est sous haute protection policière
mais pour d opinion inverse ancienne
présentatrice tv elle a créé son parti
article 1 en référence à la constitution
néerlandaise qui garantit la
non-discrimination dès ses premières
lignes normalise des expressions comme
texte pour les chiffons sur la tête on a
mis des îles que tu trouves ça normal
que circulent des vidéos d'intimidation
qui réclame le retour à une époque où
des personnes ont été lynchées lorsque
s'est inspirée par la politique tout le
monde finit par trouver ça normal
le racisme est banalisé la haine et
l'exclusion aussi faire entendre un
autre son cloche est plus que nécessaire
une lutte contre les discriminations qui
se joue en politique mais aussi dans la
société civile
gideon et vers lui met un rappeur
célèbre aux pays bas son combat à lui
c'est la lutte contre les contrôles au
faciès dont sont victimes les jeunes des
quartiers avec son association il a créé
une application permettant des
signalements selon la police nous sommes
ici dans une zone sensible donc la
police a le droit d'interpeller des gens
quand un levain tu n'as même pas besoin
d'avoir fait quelque chose donc
mais nous sommes dit qu'il fallait créer
une application car ça si à un moment
donné tu te rends compte que tu as été
traitées brutalement et tu vas par
exemple filmé la scène et c'est là tu
peux laisser une plainte sur notre
application
ensuite on se charge de traiter son
dossier
on regarde si on prend contact avec le
bureau anti discrimination ou avec la
police la police réticente au départ a
fini par financer une partie du
développement de l'application dans un
pays où les tensions identitaires sont
de plus en plus présente les initiatives
fleurissent sans pour autant endiguer la
progression du parti de geert wilders
qui se rêve en premier vainqueur
électorale d'une année où les populistes
européens espèrent partout l'emporter
il est
pays bas au mois de mars au mois de mai
la france au mois de septembre
l'allemagne frank engel le risque en
europe le premier des risques que c'est
ça c'est le populisme en allemagne je
dirais que la situation se présente un
peu différemment des deux autres pays en
d'autres pays c'est encore différent de
ces deux autres pays nommé c'est
relativement c'est relativement
différencier quand même le paysage mais
jeu mais je perçois les risques de
dérives de dérive populiste total mais
mon problème
quand je regarde la france et le
collègue lambertz n'a pas laissé finir
avant donc je dirais maintenant c'est
que il ya un front national qui commence
à prêcher l'isolément nationale le rejet
de l'union européenne rejette tout ce
qui n'est pas français
le retour sur la bonne vieille terre
française qui nourrira seul et contre
tout et à des pans entiers du reste du
paysage politique qui commencent à
converger vers tout cela vous parlez des
républicains par ajout diamants je parle
particulièrement des républicains en
même temps que je lis je lis
régulièrement de ses livres de
politiciens français qui t ont tendance
à paraître demain devant des échéances
électorales importantes
il ya surtout maintenant une bonne
cinquantaine de pages dans chacun de ses
livres pour dire combien la france mais
que la france et ensuite on s'occupe
peut-être de politiques et à la fin très
très propre ce moment c'est une
responsabilité collective ont toutes la
collision d'amendé vers le vert le front
national mais avec tellement d'imitateur
il ya de plus en plus de votants qui
dira mais merde alors il avait raison d
un but on préféra toujours l'original à
la copie sont allés voter pour moi c'est
évident que cette abdication du centre
de la vie politique devant la crétine
aux hits et des extrêmes surtout de
droite est en bonne partie responsables
de ce mouvement de balancier vers la
droite ex philippe l'on mette d'accord
avec avec franck et donc je pense qu'il
serait utile d'avoir une clarification
au sein de la plus grosse famille
politique européenne à laquelle franck
appartient je vois pas très bien comment
avec une nadine morano pour prendre les
mots n'ont plus de lait et donc non mais
je pense que il faut une clarification
c'est en effet ou avec monsieur urbaine
qu'il faut avec le jour
pour partie aux frontières vous prêcher
un convaincu et on en est bien d'accord
mais donc en effet moi j'ai toujours dit
que les extrêmes ne m'inquiète pas ce
qui m'inquiète c'est la dérive des
partis installés vers les extrêmes
ça c'est très inquiétant c'est si vous
voulez l'application des esprits j'aime
bien le thème que frank engel
l'utilisent c'est ça que nous devons
combattre
on ne peut pas baisser pavillon par
contre on ne peut pas nier la colère
croissante d'une partie importante de
notre population et pour l'expliquer moi
je vais pas chercher plus loin qu'en
lisant piketty je veux dire si vous
observez dont la déposition de m des
inégalités de revenus et des inégalités
le patrimoine en europe
qu'est ce que vous constatez c'est que
nous avons eu c'est à part l'épisode au
delà de la crise financière et des
années qui ont suivi mais nous avons eu
bon an mal an ce dernier quart de siècle
deux pour cent de croissance l'an
mais le profit de cette croissance
profite de cette activité économique et
se concentrent dans un nombre toujours
plus réduits demain et à un moment nos
citoyens commencent à se rendre compte
qu'ils sont tondus sur pied et je dirais
même que nos concitoyens ont été assez
patient parce que l'insurrection
électorale ne vient que maintenant alors
que ça fait 30 ans qu'on mène ces
politiques et donc il est très urgent de
changer de cap politique et ça
honnêtement dit je ne vois pas encore
arrivé et c'est le sait l'enjeu
pervenche berès la plus plus de
redistribution plus de protection
sociale c'est je crois que quand on
s'adresse à des français si on veut leur
faire aimer l'europe
il faut aussi qu'ils aiment la france il
faut qu'ils aiment les deux parce qu'il
faut que les français se sentent à
l'aise en leur pays fiers de leur pays
est fier de l'europe ce qu'on leur fera
pas aimer l'europe avec effectivement la
possibilité juste fait d'une dimension
financière plus intégré une zone euro
plus intégré mais c'est pour ça qu'on a
besoin d'une réorientation européenne et
parce que nous les socialistes français
nous plaidons depuis longtemps comme ça
en partie fait au compte ce mandat mais
pas assez parce que la réorientation
vers une stratégie d'investissement qui
s'occupe de transition écologique la
mise en oeuvre l'accord 21 de création
d'emplois c'est un chantier pour demain
mais moi ce que je ne voudrais bien
c'est quoi c'est créer de
l'investissement pour que justement au
foie
la justice sociale de la justice fiscale
c'est absolument indispensable et moi ya
deux choses qui me choquent
d'abord c'est l'idée que les élites
entre limette démocratique renonce à
défendre la question européenne au motif
que ça serait pas populaire je sais pas
si c'est oui mais c'est comme ça c'est
abandonner le terrain de la démocratie
et le laisser aux adversaires de la
démocratie il ya une autre chose qui est
assez paradoxal mais avait tout de même
c'est que madame le pen qui prétend
défendre les intérêts du peuple
ici elle vole les intérêts du peuple il
faut quand même se souvenir qu'elle
refuse de payer ce qu'elle a volé aux
contribuables européens en contournant
les règles alors justement transition
toute trouvée merci à vous pervenche
berès parce que nous avons depuis
quelques semaines notre checkpoint au
sein de cette émission notre checkpoint
qui est préparé par thomas mignon le
parlement européen réclame 300 mille
euros à marine le pen et au front
national pour avoir utilisé deux
assistants parlementaires au titre du fn
salariés par le parlement européen qui
aurait travaillé donc pour le fn de
supposés emplois fictifs david rachline
sénateurs fn a déclaré que l'olaf
l'office parlementaire de lutte
antifraude est le bras armé du parlement
européen raison pour laquelle il
s'attaque au fn checkpoint de thomas
mignon c'est maintenant
[Musique]
l'olaf s'est pointé du doigt son
indépendance est remise en cause par le
front national
le live c'est le bras armé du parlement
européen pour le fn lolush ne
s'attaquerait donc aux eurodéputés
eurosceptiques
à la demande du parlement européen
lui-même mais au fond c'est quoi le lot
c'est l'office européen de lutte
antifraude sa mission c'est de détecter
et enquêter sur les fraudes commises
avec de l'argent européen
c'est une mission d'information avant
tout l'olaf ne fait que rendre un
rapport à l'institution européenne
concernée et à l'autorité nationale
compétente et qu'est ce qui atteste de
son indépendance
sur le papier le règlement européen qui
régit le laf lui donne mandat
d'indépendance de manière théorique mais
aussi de façon très concrète
par exemple il est écrit que si son
indépendance est menacée l'olaf peut
même attaqué la commission européenne
devant la cour de justice et d enquêtes
ont été menées sur bien des
personnalités depuis la création de
l'olaf des membres du parlement des
commissaires européens et autres hauts
fonctionnaires européens
marine le pen et les autres
eurosceptiques ne sont donc pas
l'exception qu'ils prétendent être et le
parlement européen aurait-il pu
néanmoins utiliser le l'a utilisé n'est
pas le bon terme et c'est effectivement
martin schulz l'ancien président du
parlement européen qui a saisi le laf en
mars 2015
c'est en fait il faut savoir que tout le
monde peut signaler à l'olaf un soupçon
de fraude et par tout le monde il faut
comprendre tous les citoyens de l'union
européenne qui faisait des
responsabilités politiques ou non le
loft examinant toutes les informations
en toute indépendance
avant de mener les enquêtes seules pour
finalement remettre son fameux rapport
et il ne peut décider d'aucune sanction
donc il est faux de dire que lola est le
bras armé du parlement européen le lave
donc bras armé du rendu du parlement
européen c'est faux
cette stratégie en fait de postes vérité
frank engel où on peut finalement dire
un peu tout et n'importe quoi sans être
inquiété c'est la famille le pen a fait
a fait sa vie en disant tout et
n'importe quoi
envers et contre tout moi je les ai une
fois qualifié à la tribune du parlement
européen marine le pen je veux dire
représentant d'une petite entreprise
familiale française qui jusque là
n'avait refusé aucun subside européen et
ancien favori cette année et que oui que
oui le problème est que logiquement
toute cette famille ne devrait pas être
ici parce que on sert ici à la fin du
conte une cause qu'ils entendent aboli
ce serait déjà la première
la première d honnêteté d'essayer de
finalement obtenir un siège à
l'assemblée nationale et deux volets la
france au lieu de voler toute l'europe
pour la combattre si des gens si déjà on
prétend pouvoir voler pour servir sa
cause ce qui n'est pas mon attitude m'a
écouté merci de nous avoir éclairé sur
cette question de l'avenir de l'union
on suivra bien entendu les festivités
autour des 60 ans du traité de rome ce
sera le 25 mars prochain en attendant la
semaine prochaine vous retrouverez ahmed
tazir à bruxelles très belle semaine à
tous ciao
[Musique]